hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem alien dictionary
and yes this is another problem from the
blind 75 list
this is the problem 32 a graph problem
alien dictionary i've been wanting to do
this problem for so long now and we're
finally doing it because now we actually
have lee code premium
and again thank you for all my patreon
supporters for making that possible so
let's get into the problem now
and by the way the the link to this
spreadsheet will be in the description
if you want to take a look so this is a
pretty hard
problem i will admit it's a hard graph
problem so this problem
is going to involve the algorithm
topological
sort that you may or may not have used
before you may not have even heard of
this before
topological sort involves a d a g a
directed
a cyclical graph a graph that has
directed edges but
no cycles so the premise is we're given
a new alien language that uses
english alphabet letter so it's going to
be basically lowercase a to lowercase
z but the ordering of these characters
is unknown to us now we know in regular
english
the ordering is basically a b c all the
way to z
right this is the order there's 26
characters but basically they're saying
that now we have a different ordering of
these characters and where
and the goal for us is to try to figure
it out
and what we're given to figure it out is
basically a
list of words which happen to be given
to us
in sorted order they say lexographically
sorted that's basically just sorted
based on
how regular sorting of words works so
our goal is to return
a string of the unique characters that
were given
in this new alien language based on the
words that were given
and we're going to return this in sorted
order in increasing order
based on the new language's rules now if
there is
no solution we're returning an empty
string so we have to figure out what
that even
means what does it mean for there to be
no solution
and also there could possibly be
multiple solutions and if there are
luckily for us we're allowed to return
any of the valid solutions
now they tell us that two strings s and
t
s is going to be smaller than t if
at the first letter where they differ
the letter in
s comes before the letter in t in the
alien language and this is pretty
intuitive like
if we know if we were given two words
such as
apple and banana how are we gonna
sort these two words well we're gonna
look at the first character right we see
okay the first characters are
different and a we know a is less than b
right that's how the ordering works in
english so we're going to check
just the first differing character since
a is less than b
that means a comes first in the ordering
so how would we order these words
basically how they're listed right now a
apple comes before banana what if we
were given a different word
such as apple and ape well in that case
we look at the first characters okay
they're the exact same so we still don't
know how to sort them yet right we look
at the second characters
p p they're the exact same we look at
the third characters
p and e and we know in english
the letter e comes before p right so
the correct ordering of these words is
going to be the opposite it's going to
be ape
and then apple right so that's how we
would sort these words now
the difference in this problem is that
the input that we're given
is already sorted right so these words
are
already sorted so we're going to use
that to our advantage to basically
figure out the ordering of the
characters character by character
and there's just one edge case we have
to worry about so if
we're given two words where they have
the exact
same prefix right where basically the
shorter word
is a prefix of the longer word if that's
the case
that means the smaller word is always
going to become
first in the ordering so for example if
we had one word
ape and another word apes no matter
what since see since these words since
this word is basically a prefix of the
second word
they match right so whatever the longer
word is gonna be is always going to come
after the shorter word and if that was
not the case what if we were given a
list of words where that was not the
case what if we were given
apes and then we were given ape well
based on what they just told us that's
invalid right they say the opposite must
be true so what we can say is if we ever
see
something like this in our list of words
then we know there's no solution and
that's going to be
one case where we return an empty string
so they tell us that this input list of
words
is supposed to be in sorted order so
we're going to use that to our advantage
and so remember if these two words are
in sorted order how was it determined
that they're in sorted order how was it
determined that this word
must come after this word well it must
be based on the first
differing character right that's what
lexographically ordered
means so let's just go for every pair of
words
let's go character by character and find
the first
differing character and see what kind of
information that gives
us so let's look at the first characters
well they're the exact same
let's look at the second characters
they're the exact same let's look at the
third characters
they're different we have a t that comes
before an
f so that must mean in the alien
alphabet
t comes before f so
this is not in regular english this
isn't true but in our alien language
this seems to be the case
so let's just keep track of that let's
just remember okay
t comes before f
next let's look at the next two words so
we're going to look at the first two
characters and immediately they're
different so we know that these two
words were sorted based on this first
character
and we know that e comes after w because
they're in that order we have a
character w and we know for sure
e is going to come after that w now who
knows maybe there are some characters in
between here right maybe
it's actually going to be w f
e something like that right but we don't
really know that for sure
all we know so far is this is true and
this is true that's all we can assume
from this ordering right we know that
these first two characters
are in that order but the remainder of
the characters might be in any order
right because
when words are sorted they're only
sorted on the most significant
differing character so now let's look at
the next two words
look at comparing each first character
they're the exact same let's go to the
next character
r and t now they're different so now we
know for sure
r comes before t so let's go ahead and
do that
in our drawing right r comes before t
now we see that we already have a t in
our graph right
and actually i haven't actually
mentioned that this is a graph but it's
starting to get intuitive why we would
want to represent these relationships as
a graph now right
we could separately say r t but why not
include this node that we already have
so we know
r comes before t we know this for sure
now time to finally look at the last two
pair of words
look at the first two characters e and r
so that's the first differing
pair so we know that e comes before
r and we know that r is actually already
in our graph so then we can say okay
let's
take this edge and then hook it up over
here so once you recognize that you can
use those relationships of characters
and the relative order of those
characters to build a graph this problem
becomes
doable right then all we need to do is
now traverse this graph now
in this example it's pretty
straightforward right clearly we see
that the order is non-ambiguous right
we're going to start with a w
then e then r then t then f
and that's you know going to be the
entire order and you can see
that this order is also in the output
that they gave us
in this example so this matches up
pretty easily so you'd think okay at
this point the problem is easy but
actually there's a lot of different ways
this graph can be represented
and traversing the graph itself is not
super intuitive
and there are multiple ways to do it you
can do a bfs solution a breadth first
search solution
or you can do a depth first search
solution and i
much prefer the dfs solution there's so
many more like bookkeeping things you
need to do with the bfs solution
that i don't really think it's worth
doing i think the dfs solution even
though it's recursive is just so much
better so that's what i'm going to be
focusing on
so let's change this problem slightly
let's say that this
f actually pointed at the w
so now if we were traversing this graph
what the heck would the relative order
be we could start at any node we could
start at
r and then say okay t f w e and then we
say okay we got back to r so we already
visited that but is that a valid order
like this is
very ambiguous it's not that this has
multiple solutions it's that this is
invalid there's a contradiction right
what if we had a shorter cycle what if
we had okay w
and then e comes after w and then w
comes after e do you see how that's a
contradiction
we can't have opposite rules right it's
basically like if we had an input list
of words
that was something like this we had w e
and then e e so clearly we have a
different character here meaning e
comes after w like this but then maybe
we got that same word w-e
so how can we say that this list of
words is sorted
when you know the same word is in both
positions and then there's another word
in between that
that doesn't make sense basically that's
how you know that there's a
contradiction in that case we return the
empty string there's no real solution
and we know that because there exists a
cycle in our graph now what if this last
word in our input actually didn't exist
what if we cross it out
in that case we would never get this
connection where e
hooks up to r we have two separate
graphs right but there's no
contradiction here it's just that now we
have multiple solutions so we could say
okay the relative order
is either we are tf right basically
going through this
and then doing this one right or we
could even do it in the opposite order
rtf we right
that's one way or we could even do a
breath first search approach right put
these two first wr then put these two
e t and then put f right all that really
matters is that
this like if there's a connection if
there's a directed edge from this node
to this node all that matters is when we
return the output string
this character shows up before this one
and similarly this character shows up
before this one
and this character shows up before this
one etc etc
we really need to guarantee that that's
the case so at this point you might
think okay let's just start
at the beginning of each of these
components and then just go through it
right like say okay w
e r t f and then just build the output
string like that
and i'll show you one reason why that's
actually not gonna work
if we were given an input list of words
like this
what we would we would end up getting is
basically a graph that looks like this
and this is a perfectly valid graph
right
what's one valid ordering of this well
basically
abc right that's one valid ordering but
let's say we did a dfs
search on this let's say we started our
dfs here
so we got an a in our output then let's
say we went to this node first
then we got a c in our output then
fro from our dfs then from a you know we
see this is the base case from then we
go back up to a we say okay now let's go
to b
in our dfs so then we got a solution a c
b now from our b what we're going to end
up doing is going to c
so in reality c should come after b
but we see in our input it came before b
so basically from our dfs we got an
invalid ordering
of this graph so you know if we're doing
a dfs from the beginning
how do we know that we should be going
down this path
down to the b before we go down the c
path
well the answer is we don't really have
a good way of knowing if we're doing
this with dfs
but there is a workaround solution to
that
and the solution to that is going to be
doing a post
order dfs so in reality
yes we're going to be starting at this
node but we're not going to be
adding it to our output yet we're going
to be adding this to our output
last so okay we're here so now we're
gonna get to c
right now we're at c now we're gonna go
farther down see we see c does not have
any children right
so that's our base case so now since
this is post order
now we're gonna actually add c to the
output so now we're going to end up
popping back to a
right so we're now back at a so we're
going to continue the dfs this is post
order let's do all of our descendants
before we process a so let's go to b
okay b
that's and b has some neighbors down to
c okay we see c
has already been processed no need to do
that again so b
does not have any more descendants so
now we can process
b let's add b to the output and now
finally we can process
a right so what you see is that the way
we did it now
was not ambiguous right we didn't end up
we made sure we ended up doing
all the leaf nodes right the last nodes
of first and then these nodes
and then we finally did a last so what
you can see
is that we actually built our result in
reverse
order which isn't bad because easily we
can take this and reverse it right so we
can
when we get the output of this we're
going to make sure to reverse it before
we return
it so we're going to return abc so
that's the main idea of what i'm going
to be doing when we're actually writing
the code that's kind of how topological
sort is
done that's how i was taught to do it in
school so it's just a dfs
except we're building the result in
reverse order
and there's one last thing we're going
to have to keep track of what we're
going to be doing for
loop detection and really what we're
going to be keeping track of is two
things
similar to how i did it in the picture
we're going to be marking if a node has
already been visited meaning it's
already been let's say
processed or whatever and in this case
we know that there weren't any loops
well actually one thing i want to say is
first we saw that c was processed right
then we went back to a and then we went
to b
right when we went from b to c we saw
that c
was already processed but that doesn't
necessarily mean that we have a cycle
in our graph because yes this was
processed but it wasn't
currently being visited if we went to c
and then
c went back to b right and then we got
to b and then we tried to go
to c again that would indicate a cycle
basically if this was
currently being visited but once we once
we go from here
see it's a base case and then pop back
to a
then we're saying this is no longer
being visited so what we're going to be
keeping track of is two things
we want to know if a node has already
been visited meaning it's you know
already been processed pretty much
and we also want to know if a node is in
our current
path so we're gonna be doing that with a
dictionary and
if uh so every time we visit a node
we're gonna say it's added to the
dictionary but we're gonna give it a
false value in the dictionary and once
it's it's actually in the current path
that we're traversing
then we're going to give it a value of
true in the dictionary
with that being said we can now jump
into the code the overall time
complexity is just going to be the
number of characters that were given
in the input because that's basically
going to determine how big our graph can
be and of course we're going to have to
traverse the entire graph
so it's the the time complexity is just
going to depend on the number of
characters
so this is going to be a long one about
30 lines of code so the first thing
we're going to want to do
is going to create that adjacency list
right basically based on the ordering of
the characters
so for every single character in our
entire list of words what we want to do
is map it to
let's say a set we could do a list but a
set
is gonna make sure that we don't have
duplicates so we're gonna go through
four
every word in our list of words and then
for every character
in each word we want every character to
be mapped
to a set and then we want to go through
every pair of words so for i
in range the number of words that were
given minus
one so that we would go through every
single pair let's get
each pair so word one and word two
word one is going to be the word index i
word two is gonna be the word at index
i plus one so let's get the minimum
length of both of these two words so
let's get the minimum of the length of
each of them
and the first thing i'm going to check
is basically that base case that edge
case that we first mentioned so
mainly if the minimum length of each
word
is the exact same right meaning the
prefix of the words is the exact same
but the first word is longer than the
second word in which case we know that
we have an
invalid ordering right that's kind of
the edge case that they sp
explicitly mentioned so the length of
word one
is greater than the length of word two
they have the exact same prefix meaning
that it's an invalid ordering basically
so in that case we would have to just
return an empty string
if that's not the case we want to go
through every single character
uh between these words so basically in
range
min length and our goal is to find the
first
uh differing character right so if the
characters are the same we're not going
to do anything but if the characters are
different so
the character at position j in word one
is different from the character at
position j
in word two other they're different not
equal then we're gonna break but before
we break
we're breaking because we only want the
first differing character so we don't
want to look at any subsequent
characters but
before we break we want to add this to
our adjacency list so we want to say
that the character in word two comes
after the character in word one so we're
going to indicate that by saying okay
word one
is the key at index j and to that we're
going to be adding
word to so that's our adjacency list is
going to work out
so once we do this we can actually start
doing our dfs and remember for our dfs
we're going to be making sure to keep
track of visited nodes
so we're going to use a hash map or
dictionary and for each
node or each character we're going to be
mapping it to two values
false basically means that the character
has been visited
true means visited and
it's been it's in the current path right
so
clearly if it's in the current path that
means it's been visited right so
saying it's visited is basically
redundant but true
indicates that it's in the current path
if it's not added to the visit
dictionary at all that means it hasn't
been visited at all
we also want to maintain a result and
remember we're going to be building this
in reverse order so i'm actually going
to make it a list
initially and then we're gonna join the
characters in that list at the end
in reverse order so we can define our
dfs function all we need to do is pass
in the current character or node that
we're visiting
now if character is already in visit
then we're just going to return
now what are we going to return we're
going to return the value that's stored
in visit so
if it's already been visited then we're
just going to return false if it's
if it's in the current path then we're
going to return true now if this dfs
ever returns true that means we saw a a
character or
node that was already in this in the
current path
and we saw it twice that means we
detected a loop so if this returns true
that's how you know we detected a loop
if this
if this is not the case then what we're
going to say is okay visit
to to visit at this character we're
going to be adding true because not only
has it been visited
it's also in the current path and then
at the end
before we return we're going to say okay
visit of c is now
false meaning it's still been visited
but now it's false because it's no
longer in the current path that's what
we're gonna do right before we return
but
before we do that we're gonna go through
a loop we're gonna go through every
neighbor or descendant or
character that comes after this
character so basically from our
adjacency list that we built earlier
we're going to go through every
character that's a neighbor of c
and we're going to run dfs on that
neighbor now if this returns false so if
or rather if this returns
true that's how you know that we have a
loop so if this returns true then we are
going to return true
immediately telling you know the
recursive call that we basically
detected a loop and we can return
immediately okay so that's pretty much
all for our dfs but don't forget this
was a post order dfs so mainly
after we've done the recursive call
that's when we're finally gonna say okay
to
our result we can finally append this
character remember we're actually
building this in reverse order
so once we've done the entire dfs we're
gonna have to return the result in
reverse
order so now we defined our dfs so now
let's actually
call the dfs so for every single
character and we don't really need to
actually
start at the beginning character of the
graphs we can actually start at any
single character and it'll still
work out the same the reason being is
because we're doing it in reverse order
and if you don't believe me you can try
drawing out the picture and seeing what
would happen if we started it in the
middle of the graph somewhere
and it actually does surprisingly work
out as long as you do mark the
characters as visited once you actually
visit them so we go through every single
character in our adjacency list and then
we call dfs
on that character and if this returns
true
then we are also going to return then
immediately we're going to turn the
empty string meaning we detected a loop
now if that's not the case
that's when we're actually going to
return the result but remember the
result is a list so what we're going to
do
is actually join every single character
in
that list in result but before we do
that we want to make sure we reverse
the result and then we perform that join
and return
so i hope this was helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully see
you pretty soon
thanks for watching